question 412 de Monsieur Francis Grignon
à Madame la Ministre chargée des
personnes handicapées et de la lutte
contre
l'exclusion merci monsieur le ministre
monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues monsieur le ministre cette
question va peut-être vous paraître d'un
intérêt très local mais bon je suis
depuis 25 ans président d'un hôpital
psychiatrique situé dans une ville
moyenne de 10000 habitants où nous avons
la chance avec la municipalité l'ôp et
beaucoup d'associations d'avoir implanté
plus de 140 logements pour permettre aux
personnes handicapées de ne pas rester à
l'hôpital mais de vivre dans la société
civile d'où l'objet de cette question
nous avons j'ai été très ému quand j'ai
appris qu'il y aurait peut-être une
suppression des aides financières
extraalégales pour les personnes
bénéficiant de laallcation aux adultes
handicapé en effet il semblerait que la
caisse primaire d'assurance maladie du
barrain est déc cidé de supprimer les
aides financières à compté du mois de
juillet 2013 pour les personnes
titulaires de cette
AAH qui servent vous le savez bien à la
vie courante à l'aide ménagère à l'aide
aux courses et cetera cette décision
aura de nombreuses conséquences aussi
bien auprès des usagers qu'au niveau
financier pour les associations les
associations qui prennent en charge des
personnes présentant des troubles
psychiques dans le cadre de la
réinsertion par le logement Poe un
service d'aide ménagère de maintien à
domicile ce qui V souvent les
réhospitalisations la suppression de ces
aides handicapera un peu plus ces
personnes pour qui le handicap psychique
est une difficulté dans le maintien de
l'autonomie cette perte risque
d'acentuer leur isolement social à terme
ces personnes ne pourront pas être
maintenues à domicile elles risqueent de
rechuter et d'être réhospitalisé le coût
de C ces
réhospitalisations sera bien évidemment
supérieur à celui des aides versés
nonont-ils bénéficié jusqu'à présent
d'autre part ces
associations n'ayant plus pardon les
financements nécessaires devront
éventuellement licencier une partie de
leur personnel je souhaiterais donc
savoir Monsieur le Ministre si vous
entendez maintenir la suppression de ces
aides financières extralégales pour les
personnes bénéficiant de
l'allocation aux adultes handicapés
merci monsieur le
ministre
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Sénateur Grignon je prie tout d'abord de
bien vouloir excuser la ministre
déléguée auprès de la ministre des
Affaires sociales et de la santé qui est
dans l'impossibilité d'être
présente ce matin qui m'a demandé de
vous répondre je tiens tout d'abord à
préciser que les aides extralégales que
vous mentionnez que les caises Primaires
d'Assurance Maladie dispens relèvent de
leur action sanitaire et sociale et sont
à ce titre de la compétence locale le
gouvernement ne supprime aucun cas des
aides qu' n'a pas la charge d'accorder
ni de cibler l'amélioration de l'accès
aux soins de tous en particulier des
personnes handicapé est au cœur de
l'action gouvernementale elle s'est
traduite dans l'effet par l'augmentation
de 7 % du plafond de l'éligibilité à
l'aide à l'acquisition d'une
complémentaire santé inscrite dans le
plan pluriannuel de lutte contre la
pauvreté cette augmentation permettra à
terme de couvrir 750000 personnes de
plus par la CMU et la CS
parmi ces ces 750000 personnes au moins
100000 sont aujourd'hui bénéficiaires de
la loocation adulte handicapé ils
pourront ainsi bénéficier d'une aide
supplémentaire à l'accès aux soins à cet
égard l'initiative de la CPAM du Barin
sincrit dans la ligne que le président a
fixé de généralisation de la couverture
complémentaire à tous les Français lors
du congrès de la mutualité en octobre
2012 elle complète en quelque sorte la
mesure nationale du plan de lutte contre
la pauvreté à majorant via des aides
extalégales le soutien financier apporté
au bénéficiaires de la CS et de la CMU
les personnes handicapées sont
aujourd'hui plus nombreuses à bénéficier
d'une complémentaire santé le
gouvernement reste par ailleurs
extrêmement vigilant au fait que l'accès
aux soins à la fois sanitaire et d'aide
à la vie quotidienne des personnes
handicapées s'améliore dans le cadre du
droit commun la CPAM du barrain a veillé
à ce qu'il y ait un temps de de
transition dans le reciblage de ces
aides ext légal en faveur d'une
généralisation de la mutualisation qui
couvrira aussi les bénéficiaires de Laah
par ailleurs ces derniers peuvent
cumuler Laah avec la PCH que leur
handicap soit psychique ou non nous
serons très attentifs à ce que la
qualité de prise en charge ne diminue
pas pour ces
personnes merci monsieur le ministre
monsieur Grignon bien il va falloir que
j'analyse en détail cette réponse
monsieur le Président parce que ça
devient très technique vous dites en
préambule monsieur le ministre que ça
dépend de la Caisse Primaire d'Assurance
Maladie locale et pas du gouvernement
certes mais j'attire votre attention sur
le fait que tout ce qu'on supprime ce
qui relève du domaine social on le
retrouvera dans le domaine sanitaire et
ça c'est le gouvernement bien donc il
faut vraiment veiller à ce que les
choses s'équilibrent bien quant à votre
réponse j'avoue que je ne suis pas assez
technicien pour l'analyser je fais
l'affaire analyser chez moi je vais
aller dans le détail
et je verrai si elle répond vraiment à
la question que j'ai posée merci